what's going on everybody it's Jake and
welcome back to another Elden ring
discussion video today I'd like to talk
about Fara Missoula because mainly I
haven't done so very often on this
channel I've actually only made one
video in the past year that has to do
with this area and honestly I'm not even
sure why I made a theory during that
video that I don't think I explained
very well back then I claimed that it
could be possible that the Pharaoh
Missoula that we see out in the distance
from melania's Divine Tower is different
from when we are actually there I even
went as far to call it a Dream Within
Melina as she is the one that seemingly
puts us to sleep at the forge of the
Giants and then we randomly wake up in
Fair Missoula kind of like how Thea's
dream and the fortisax boss fight work
in terms of a dream state I've always
found this to be a strange coincidence
but then again what isn't strange in the
lands between I do think that that video
I made is a bit outdated at this point
and deserves a follow-up explanation on
what I now believe in regards to pherom
as first I'd like to bring up a few key
differences between the structure we see
from afar versus the area that we play
the game in from a distance we can see
one giant tornado that is surrounded
with the same structural layout and
ruined debris that we can see when we
are actually there however there seems
to be a lack of dragons flying around
this debris when looked at from a
distance now this could be a rendering
issue meaning they didn't want to devote
memory space to having these dragons fly
around at all times even from a distance
or there are simply just no dragons a
better example of what I'm talking about
goes back to the one giant tornado e
word there being one tornado when we can
clearly see when we're in faramezula
that there are actually Four tornadoes
surrounding this area now again this
could be a rendering issue but I think
removing three big tornadoes from an
environment from any distance wouldn't
really be something from software would
do aramezula is a very important moment
in the game so I doubt they just remove
move key information like this in terms
of environmental storytelling this is of
course one of the most important ways
that from software actually tells the
story of the world that we play in so
three tornadoes missing and really tell
us a lot finally I'd like to bring up
the lack of a day and night cycle in
pharamazula meaning that the time of day
just never changes when we're there
which is obviously quite different from
every other area in the lands between
that does have a day and night cycle now
I no longer believe that pharah Missoula
is a dream state I do believe that it is
a physical place because we can see a
version of it from a distance as
thousands of people let me know in the
comments of that video from a year ago I
always wonder if people look at the
comments that have already been posted
before posting a comment that's already
been said many times anyway it doesn't
really matter what does matter is
getting what I mean across in an
understandable way to you guys so it's
really my fault to begin with what I'm
trying to say is that the Pharaoh
Missoula we play in is a different
version of pharah Missoula that we can
see from melania's tower for example yes
it is the same area with the same layout
surrounded by the same giant tornado in
the same ruined debris but what I now
believe is that it is in a different
time in space I understand this is going
to be even more confusing than the
original video but I'm going to try my
best to explain before I do I'd like to
give credit to quetzalcoat 101 who
posted the majority of this theory in
our Discord Community server his post
really opened my eyes to new
possibilities with faramazula along with
thinking more logically sometimes with
Elden ring as many of the game's main
themes can be inspired and based on real
world aspects including physics gravity
general relativity and time dilation he
said he was inspired by this Theory
after one of our community live streams
which I have started a new channel for
recently AGT Jake live is up and running
now so go subscribe with the link in the
description if you want to so faramazula
itself self is an interesting place I do
not necessarily think it is in a
different time period during the time of
when we play the game but there is
definitely
um time Shenanigans going on here the
idea that pharah Missoula is within a
different timeline is likely came about
due to the fact that dragon lord plus
citizacks namingly separated part of
pharamazula and placed it outside of
time however I do not think that the
time warping done by Placida sacks
affected all of pharah Missoula equally
and as we think about this here are some
observations to consider first the
massive tornado in the center second the
floating Rubble around that tornado and
finally the presence of malikath Bernal
and Alexander in this area according to
the dragonlord remembrance this tornado
or storm that holds placidus acts within
the heart of that storm is beyond time
this corresponds well to the fact that
to fight Placida sax aim itself seems to
reverse as the tarnish character enters
the tornado this provides valuable
information it suggests to us that we
fought placidus acts in the past but
even this may not be entirely true the
tornado is the storm Beyond time but
what does beyond time even mean well
let's think logically on that according
to Einstein's theory of general
relativity I'm in space are inseparable
that's why the term space-time exists
base time itself is distorted via
objects with mass like dark matter black
holes planets or even Stars this creates
a bubble in space-time that creates what
we call gravity disparities in gravity
and velocity create something called
time dilation and a simple way to give
you an example of this is from the film
Interstellar the gravitational pull on a
planet that is near a large black hole
compared to the pole of Earth's gravity
to the sun is so much stronger that time
is actually slowed down every hour they
spent on a planet near the black hole
would be seven years back on Earth
that's relativity folks Beyond Time
could simply mean that time dilation
exists and is created by the tornado in
faramezula acting as a sort of black
hole for example I'm dilation means that
we can look at pharamazula as it is
crumbling but time can pass at a
different rate within or around the
tornado as such when we technically
fight Placida sex we would be fighting
him Beyond time or in a space where the
time dilation doesn't exist this leads
into the second observation the floating
rocks and ruins these are interesting
for one reason they don't move the ruins
and rocks are held in place as if they
are static only moving very slightly if
at all this could not be possible if the
Rocks were held up by the force of the
Winds from the tornado as such there is
something else going on and this
something else I believe Gravity the
Rocks themselves only travel and hover
around the tornadoes and given what we
discussed about the tornado iron
dilation only occurs with a disparity in
gravity and because of this it stands to
reason that the tornadoes are themselves
somehow able to create a massive
gravitational pull to create a literal
orbit holding the ruins up in place
similar to how our sun holds the planets
in place around our own solar system
finally our last observation the
presence of malekith Bernal and
Alexander in faramazula I believe that
this proves that the actual physical
thermezula we walk and explore in is
within the same time frame as the lands
between the fact that individuals are
able to both travel to affect and travel
from faramazula knows that the time
dilation of the tornado does not affect
the rest of the area but does hold it up
via the force of gravity meaning
individuals can go in and out of these
areas I'm still not sure how but
obviously they can but their time and
space is still affected the same as
anyone else's would this could explain
the major differences between malacath
and his seemingly Alter Ego grank in the
beastial sanctum but I'm still not
completely sure on this but that's why
this is a discussion video please let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments I thought this was an extremely
interesting topic to bring up obviously
all of this information is up in the air
and heavily interpreted so take it as
you will and however you want that's all
for me today thank you all for watching
and I'll see you in the next video take
care